[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody what's up how's it
going happy Tuesday Persia here David is
back and today we are playing some
half-life the original number one GOG mm
where it all began and obviously we are
playing half-life because we're excited
David more so than myself
because he is the half-life veteran here
but yeah we heard about the
announcements about the newest iteration
yeah project Alex yeah the VR game yeah
it's gonna come out in march 2020
I mean they just kind of dropped that
trailer the bombshell on us everyone was
hoping it was gonna be half-life 3 and
the rumors came out was like no it's not
gonna be a third one it's gonna be a
prequel and it's gonna be VR and then
everyone was like but then the trailer
came out and I mean for me personally
I'm I'm hyped I think I think it's
pretty dope I think it's very really
cool so we'll have to see what happens
but it uh it should be good we've got
half-life one here ready to go for you
guys and we're gonna we're gonna play
through it really see how far we get
yeah and we'll
this automated train is provided for the
security and convenience personally I'm
a big fan of er any personnel so I'm
interested in it just because I'm very a
what do you say I really like VR yeah so
yeah but I haven't really played
half-life the original one so I guess
for me personally my interest in Alex is
just the VR aspect of it but you know
I'm always down to go back and check out
games that I haven't had the pleasure of
playing throughout my lifetime you know
the in the beginning just now while
we're on this little [ __ ] who saw that
security guard those like pounding the
door yeah that's Barney counters he you
actually play us in half-life pollution
[Music]
before deals he's pretty cool yeah and
it's cool because you play as from his
perspective and you try to escape the
facility but it's it's pretty good and
the half-life universe has a lot of
times too I mean I'm sure you're
familiar with a like portal so the whole
company behind portal right there called
Aperture Science they are kind of like a
competing
okay so they got their compound they got
their own things there and it's it's
it's really interesting and there are
some areas in the and the trailer for
project Daleks where it made me think of
after science there were certain areas
and I wonder if they're gonna like
allude more and tease more of the two
different companies noice noice what's
up Brandon he says hi / - hi David
welcome back I know something's going
down
[Music]
sound like a good idea
staying away from electrified realize
full eighty-eights as I remember being
incredibly impressed with the graphics
back in the day for sure that's a good
thing with all of kind of like valve is
half-life stuff right when have like one
came out everyone was like this is
insane
and then when half-life 2 came out it
was like the same thing like this is
nuts right the source engine was super
super cool I remember playing this I was
man I was a kid I was like maybe seven
eight years old and it's scared hello
oh my goodness this game was terrifying
man absolutely sir are you trying to
scare me here David I mean you know me
you know I can't I can't do scary games
yeah they sure like I genuinely
you can't stand them but for some reason
that mean hello Balki gaming alright so
this came out in 1998 that is a long
time ago 20 years ago yeah it is Wow
I was seven when this game came out
Oliver says the scheme was a foundation
for a lot of other games to come I can
see that this whole section is it's
fairly long you're basically kind of
traveling through the entire Black Mesa
facility and like I almost feel like
this was kind of showing off a little
bit oh here we go another person you
know who that is
we seem that thumbnails on all the
projects out oh yeah the g-man oh oh
that thing's weekend oh you noticed that
[Laughter]
so we are Gordon Freeman's like a 27
year old theoretical physicist from MIT
as a PhD guy super super smart and he's
about to oh dang I gotta wait for the
yellow homie put a pep in your step
we gotta get out of here thank you
there's stuff leaking in the other room
not about it oh well maybe if you hurry
that bow
I saw off the way for him not the way
for him to come over here and like open
this door for me yeah I do enjoy going
back and check me out older games seeing
how far we've come but also being like
appreciative of what was already ahead
of its time right
and wonderful who's anyone in in chat he
was like remembers the first time
playing half-life they like particularly
if they're you know older than us right
there maybe in their teens or their
adult years and they really thought this
was like yeah so he's basically trying
to say like you know hey get your stuff
together you know you're you've got
people need you here you've got an
important old test you got to take part
of that you're late to I'm like all
right so we got to find our our suit we
gotta go to the personal facilities Jaco
and the chat very adamant about Poland's
love for half-life you say greetings
shut up here we go Freeman okay actually
I don't have my seat just yet gotta go
here we go Logan says I remember playing
as an eight-year-old and it was so
amazing
yeah for sure I played the game super
late I didn't play it when it came out I
think I played it in like the early 2000
what's going on Andrew how you doin have
Tuesday you guys got some turkey day
plans out there it's only a few days
away yeah man thanks morning thanks
gaming it was one thing I would love to
do I would make I'd have like my friends
play or my siblings play and I would
save right before but then I would like
knock them off so they so they die what
you do is you jump off and then and you
save when you're in mid-flight so big
yeah there Luke there's no way to get
out of it I mean you can really mess
with people in games oh yeah
all right so many people in chat saying
they missed the scheme or they're gonna
go back and play it again
definitely do for sure going back to the
throwbacks all right I forgot what uh
what's the name of the test lab around
see we can find it I feel like I'm
seeing the same people in every room oh
they are oh for sure sorry they're not
they're not the same very concerned that
we get a conclusive analysis of today's
sample I gather they went to some
lengths to get it yeah so they're just
gonna be talking about the fact they're
like oh this you know little test that
you're gonna do I don't know if it's
gonna fully work like one of them is is
a little concerned he's saying like no
this isn't a good idea I don't think
this is uh this is the right you know
type of test that we should do maybe
it's not moral maybe it's dangerous
and the other two are like no no what
the administration really wants us to to
get a conclusive test and you're
noticing like these are breaking yeah
these guys are freaking out you know
portals oh yeah exactly
I felt like VR has come a long way I
feel like the album's gonna be the one
that really makes me our less gimmicky
and more I played a bunch of VR like
thinking back to like the first few VR
experiences I've had compared to the
ones I've had more recently it's
definitely much more smooth interact
with the environment cabinets and like
shelves to find ammo like it's it's I
think it's cool I think it might be the
thing that makes we are a little uh a
little more compelling and I mean it
wouldn't be the first time that valve
kind of ushered in and you like era with
tech so we're gonna go and turn
something on I'm gonna go fix the place
I totally understood all of that is you
I'm so unlike all this science jargon
that went through one year and out the
other
[Music]
[Music]
yo this looks like a safe place to stand
nice
all according to plan smooth sailing I
guess we fixed it guys we can go home
tom says he like the half-life spinoff
games me too man opposing force and blue
shift they're very very good it's the
same game but just from different
perspectives and you would take like
different routes and stuff and it was it
was really cool it just added to the
story
[Music]
[Music]
this feels like being in lyon like a
Disney attraction for that but
interactive stuff yeah oh yeah we gotta
push this thing into the put that stick
of butter
oh they're dead well yeah we gonna
answer that
what is happening yeah just take me out
see all right there we go Thanks check
it out though
here heartbeat all right we back
oh whoa hey not bad dear oh okay that's
a no from me yeah you're not you're not
down with the vortigaunts they need to
be worth it gone forever
unforeseen consequences
all right we got a GTFO so at this point
you're like was that a dream because I
pass out or did I actually go we got
that monotone keeps s opposing force is
better than glue ship you're correct
oh dang oh he's that to him Rose a
health pack right here what are you
doing man
[Music]
oh you know those portals oh the red one
Oh Oh No we're gonna become very well
acquainted with these boys later
Oh No
access denied I gotta get this guy to
fall you know the crazy thing is I
really don't doubt that like something
like this guy have any real life sure
people do an experiment to test China
open portals it's not an actual being
like the hydrant Collider is some
craziness that's like in existence
follow me bro let's go pretty quick we
gotta be careful here
sorry you literally have zero health 566
oh good
I was looking at the little zero next to
you oh yeah that's the that's like
you're ooh
here we go Oh rhobar trust me
that's brutal
oh my god you can like kill the the
scientists too you just you just can't
kill a scientist once he gets Oh gross
that definitely like oh we have a gun
though
[Music]
[Applause]
shame they take a lot of shot yeah I
think we're playing on art which is why
they're taking some bullets grab that
crowbar became an iconic symbol in
gaming one hundred percent
I think it might have been game informer
or maybe even GameSpot before I started
working here like years ago when they
were talking about like iconic weapons
mmm and 100% crowbar was on that it's
just I don't know it's just crazy
I'm gonna change one thing real quick
because I think my sprint has gone to
maybe I'm just used to maybe there is no
sprite spoiled no use boiled game raves
so there's the walk and all right I
don't know maybe we'll try he's when I
when I hold my spare button is usually
just walking in there might be a head
Packers oh there he is oh he got
squished trying to fight him off oh I
miss bulletproof glass
you got got maybe uh you want you to
taking notes from the glass here this
guy having a seizure
oh yeah that's it not crazy
oh that ammo yeah I got some ammo
thanks guys it's like half happening in
like half a pug yep right Labin or
others mazes
they're like little hams I know right
try to help you like they can swim and
you just okay so we got to get to the
other side and the way that we do this
is by I don't have to turn on the water
I'm just trying to remember if I can so
I don't end up drowning I think
[Music]
Oh mega Lord said it's called strafe
jumping that of Sprint right okay so you
just it's like the I know what it means
you just jump in or I would jump in
charge at the same time
oh you're gonna love this part and I say
right here you can keep an eye up and
see what starts coming down
oh I'm kind of cute little man a little
slide that's cute at first there's like
a million of them here I'm definitely
not for the hit
I remember thinking like my dodged all
of them that was like the best thing to
do but the problem is is that they go
bottom yeah they go to the bottom and
they're just waiting for you
great batter up
ah
well well very literally craps craps it
go on your head
that guy's chillin you're like you'll
catch it - yeah
are you still alive
[Music]
anything good in these some good Ana
that good snack
oh my goodness
voila we've said this is the longest
game I've ever played
how will you it's it's pretty long it's
like a it's like a solid fourteen or
sixteen chapters it's pretty long
yeah so it's a good amount especially
for oh my
[Applause]
I'm not even supposed to jump there huh
a half-life movie hmm don't know how
bill about seeing live-action headcrabs
I mean hey you can see them in VR right
it's got a beginner nothing barnacles
well right there the fighting back now
they got some projectiles and I know aim
though
a lot of life
of the screen
and Richie in the chat says I remember
all the platforms
[Music]
my claustrophobic
always
[Music]
oh that was a big jump there that's why
I like save right before yeah and one
more in there we go she's just like
narrate everything I do in life like
this isn't it kind of like weave through
Bart trains find the seat yeah hello
Shahir how's it going so all that just
like just to get across made it
alright chapter 3 office complex
[Music]
nice oh I heard movement and and now
he's gone bro Matt says damn I feel
young again kissing this game on the
screen I can see that just full
disclosure I don't know if it's here but
there are definitely there's definitely
headcrabs that like lying wait in these
shoes because it's so hard to see what's
around the corner right oh you just go
and there just there oh I thought he was
climbing the Rope up to another floor
but it's definitely a barnacle he's
getting eated oh wow he's still alive
hi I saved him nice you should thank me
girl okay so we open this door just like
we turn off the electricity so I can
actually go
Oh doors locked
oh that fan right that fan that was
preventing us
[Music]
I just can't it's gotta be with me -
dead end
[Music]
20 minute speed around of hath life
someone has done that is that what
they're saying yeah this mindset in the
chat that's crazy
owner how much of this 20 minutes was
spent in that the tram in the beginning
yeah of course
well that is why I just be so but we
also do need to get there cuz that doors
locked
oh you must have that thing on for a
long time tried to take know his hands
you put all these boxes in the way whoa
hi buddy
hey buddy you can open this door for me
bud sick amen
get you a mo real quick
he was so nice to you okay you saved
right before though I know yeah well cuz
sometimes if you do it but like they're
necessary to like open a door maybe then
the game like it's like a game over you
know what I mean like I'll just be like
oh you have to you can't kill those guys
but they're not particularly essential
so we do need to go in here you know
don't land in the water yeah for sure
well I think yeah what is okay yeah
scared for you yeah
noise oh I forgot your head chopped I
[Laughter]
was trying to get into their Wiley man
okay I think I got some jump si Woo's so
what some jump see wound get all your
jump see black screen see jump see yeah
[Music]
we're just we're just lucky that there's
only one type of headcrab in half-life 1
I'd like to messed me
oh yeah about that Oh who invented this
room metal box metal box
[Music]
so you can say any scientist man Marge
MC woo okay you don't have the hops no
maybe if I can pull this whatever I
don't need it you know you don't mess
with that okay just get some shotgun
ammo it's a pistol ammo I'll be fine
I'll be fine
there's a lot of doubling back
oh hey party in Sector D yeah we got a
we got a crowbar party let's go
get some pizza easy there's another one
of those that aim yeah let's go
I liked how he was definitely not having
that he was like I'm fighting back I
like that you get to see kind of like
little things happen
[Applause]
that's crazy that was probably more
creepy than everything we've seen so far
still say there's nothing to chaos
theory you bouncing he's out to die
don't die in a crab it's the range game
guys are the radioactive life fake so
you're gonna die for the way you kill
the security that's hilarious
and I just walked by help oh I'll get it
all good guts come out again
the combos exterminator over here fake
says revenge is sweet for the security
guard you don't even know what you've
done did this could happen but the
administrator just would not listen are
you any used to he's one of them I
always away I'm on this one what did he
die now yep oh my god did what a glitch
okay that was sick
alright and all that fun and chaos
I have lost my bearings someone said no
don't kill him too late
I wonder if I could lead them to hey
come over here buddy
yeah no they're not they're not coming
to rescue you bro are you going check I
think there's a out there this
bro they're not coming here to save you
performing witchcraft
you know how monkey is like look for
parasites on each other's back Richie
it's too late he's a madman everyone
dies today
yeah cool espresso machine they're just
minding their own business yeah but I do
need help
I would have actually left them alone
I've been fine Oh what yeah it's like
not even moving relax
I got some meat we're in the meat locker
man these guys are probably made
probably my biggest fear I just tanks
they're really ugly looking like super
just watch it and I god I hate them and
they ever project them yes
but a miss bro okay I have to bring this
like this game was released in 1998 for
Wakko and the chat he was asking about
it 1998 I hear ya
whoo I always get motion sickness when I
watch other people play a first-person
mean I was gonna ask you actually I was
like a few I don't know if you feel if
you're gonna start feeling a little
queasy because the way that this game
like moves is pretty yeah it's pretty
out there
I got to play half-life 2 at some point
for our like most influential games of
the of the decade and it was cool you
know I was capturing footage for it but
also I was playing so much in such a
short amount of a time that I feel like
it happens mainly when I'm watching
other people because like you don't know
when the game yeah whoo that's all good
that happens with like all games for me
not just yeah
mainly like the first-person games the
most just goes like you're intending to
look a specific way and then I'm just
like rygan
[Music]
okay I was like the lights in here keep
moving around
just crawling through some shoots some
bones in your school misses school
someone was dead for a long time a
couple skulls I don't mind
[Music]
came out from there
what do you guys have planned for
Thanksgiving from 2days I'm about to
dance that's some very great gravy else
yeah what what you asked me to do
you don't watch football dear there's a
lot of football games on Thanksgiving
right they always have like that
eight-legged turkey or something
yeah it's it's pretty good when I was a
kid I thought they actually raised like
eight-legged Turkey somewhere and like
specifically brought it out for the
surface yeah that's the thing it's crazy
because they're like oh we have people
here they're here to save us and it's
like no they're here to silence everyone
he just there the door what door no
double what door he came through the
wall
[Music]
[Music]
alright let's go oh go save them yeah
I'll try and get anybody I don't think
you can't I think he's supposed to fall
[Music]
Wow he fell into the next dimension
[Music]
we've got hostiles chapter 4 yo I
respect that
oh you see what just happened that oh he
ran through the dude the laser oh my god
yeah lit up
[Music]
he got lit up so I think I think they're
starting to realize that uh they're like
people are coming to just like wipe them
out learning the others
[Music]
I thought there were like a bunch of
soldiers in here you've gunned down dad
also - I mean you're definitely we're
definitely gonna run in this one for
sure and for those guys
that was not I'm not
stopping power right next to a bunch of
explosive barrels
they were in there
[Music]
[Music]
yeah he's just like oh so this is a wet
floor I think the idea is like if you go
you just end up like sliding let me find
this over there
humph you scientist is dead for sure
that was probably yeah you almost died
you go back you only get to either one
someone said you can see the g-man maybe
I already passed it by the time I read
that but you can definitely see him in
on a couple of areas he's usually like
behind windows or he'll I mean he'll
just appear randomly and he's always he
looks like he's observing you
oh now we got the FAMAS
[Laughter]
that music
don't shoot I'm with the science team oh
you are
[Music]
we should make a beat to this tool like
bind to that help so it's a sue like
your armor it's both okay um so the
bottom left is your pen help help if
that hits zero you're dead you know to
me yeah and the the one on the bottom
right
her middle say that's your HEV suit so
that's kind of like a shield right it's
a Grover shield and there's no better
feeling and half life then getting both
of those 200 loading up and you're like
oh yeah
like I'm ready this is it
okay yeah so that area is impossible to
go to so we go in here
success we're at a hundred each we are
ready for comments
[Applause]
oh wait no that is stop running stop
running we're gonna get rekt dude
I'm with the science team as he's
getting eaten all day through that
barrel behind ya
[Music]
there's some help
there we go take a deep breath I saw in
the chat earlier talking about Black
Mesa which I also played in his it's a
lot of fun that was like I don't want to
say a fan-made sniffling community
effort though it's like a remake but not
a remake it's kind of like a
continuation oh it's a continuation of a
particular area where they essentially
added on chapter 10 I want to say of the
original half-life and they and they
made it like really clear way more in
depth a lot longer
he's one of like the most boring parts
of the game I made it really good we
actually have a gameplay clip I've been
fighting a boss you fight going arc and
that's on gamespot gameplay no eats
noise
whoo
how you feeling
[Music]
his this feels good in each old-school
looking shooter yeah Matt Parker yeah I
think I think they did use the source
engine it was it was pretty good it felt
a little long actually after a while but
it was pretty good
all right
the chopper get to the chopper out there
somewhere yes
Oh reinforcements okay in there so y'all
supposed to get to the surface it's like
no back underground
yeah
you're on a mission
maybe this was
okay
oh dang like all the bricks and suffer
very bouncy seriously
let's take a lot of damage melmax yeah I
took a lot of damage
I try to wear you down with guns they're
like see where this gun is oh oh I
definitely thought you were about to
bite fit us that's jab you up so always
get lost only shoots see how many like
different yeah I mean noise got some
bullets on the menu back up yeah okay so
we definitely went there already
beeping them
do I track down all right so this is
weird it's where do I go then no oh is
that blinking like your flashlights
right and I know no but you were right
my flashlight was running out of matter
[Music]
then this is back where we came from all
those there wait
well there's a ladder what are you thin
enough yeah so we just kind of like
loaded up I guess
got some amounts of health
[Music]
just for good measure
wow that's a little dead-end and oh my
gosh okay did I so much for the
government word
[Music]
I heard everything you said hey les bro
yeah blast it
oh no ok if I if this is what I think it
is the boss fight I don't know this is
actually how I get there or no it has to
be I think I'm missing something the
blast page I think is a
like if you didn't know anybody be like
oh they're so cute no and then they do
that
[Music]
Amos it easy okay didn't go that far I
was like oh this is because this is
radioactive gunk we've got yes is that
that what is that thing called the Giga
meter or whatever the that lace measures
what you receive measures like
radioactive about something oh we're
going oh we gonna we're infected
here's his waiting room
I was confident I mean you know I don't
I don't blame you
cuz I've not been making any of these
jumps
Oh characters I'm not satisfied with
your ability you got to land on there
yeah that's yeah for sure
oh my goodness there yeah there we go
yeah these are noggin I have no more
radioactive levels detected I'm like
making personal like both like motion
sickness and they're just like missing
in just sick period with fails
95%
I see you trying to hide behind a barrel
he's gonna sweep that would be so cool
if they mean like an actual headcrab eco
where Matt Parker says maybe we'll get a
collector's edition with a one-to-one
scale grab headcrab model and a crowbar
hekia got a pretty sick
whoa enjoy his lunch
inside of a salt rifle bullets oh look
at that guy right there if the aim
assist will let me see how that jumps
yeah Wow trying to hit the try hit these
things but you're jumping to skills to
the test again yeah seriously nice whoa
Oh later guys
oh here we go open up whoa
which is you guys links buddy yeah it
was weird
I like I like wasn't moving it was
moving basil
and he's not talking about this
talking about about the big boy
next room making all that noise oh yeah
way back thing is fantastic
this sounded like Oh me and my friends
would make our own little homey movies
in Halo 2 back in the day but the audio
quality was so bad because we were just
using like Xbox Live mics to record the
audio after you just got done your poem
with all the shotguns ding oh we got a
need so I don't remember how to deal
with this boss I think you like
staggering Oh throw some name yeah well
we got a test something at least we
could save anywhere we want so can he
hit me yes all right now let me figure
that out so I've got grenades I hurt him
enough to like make him yeah okay so
that buys me time basically
before he comes back you destroyed like
one arm I think I think he's gonna come
back I just want to like see how long
his I stink the ground for this baby
[Music]
maybe not
just for good measure down the chute
SEC okay so we got some time so we got
to look for something fast
this other side Oh God
nice way to go it's okay you can feel
camping
lacerations to take it well we're just
have to deal with it definitely would
have been right there
at least the water doesn't hurt
Chad's telling me some good advice I
think we're on the right path you got to
go down and turn on or turn off the
power
thank you for patiently waiting for me
to get my gun out
this is a massive facility it's giant
yeah for sure oh yeah we gotta take care
of all 38 life yeah exactly
we ain't got time to mess around okay
[Music]
yeah good luck I mean
okay I just have to try to I mean make
it in between I think I just jumped down
no it well you saved some check it
Geronimo oh I mean I can't go I can't go
up either hmm oh nice no just checking
again for good measure what do we do
maybe you have to go up there really
fast before it winds up maybe twice shoo
depleted this was a time to fly but how
earth why
[Music]
okay maybe is starting and then run Oh
are you ready that feels like the right
thing to do
doesn't it sin needs up says chat send
needs oh oh no oh no he's right
Oh cuz it's a fanfare yeah but it's
India I know the heck shoot it
be nice like that oh okay
we gotta time it alright got this
on - gotta cook it - no one - you know
scary
huh oh boy
helium one left oh my god what did you
do David
it's like Russian roulette I think you
need to try just going up the ladder
yeah baby oh my god this turns it back
off right or should all right you're
ready to run okay
oh good saving that all right sick
and then now it should just float you up
yeah I feel like I should just be able
to like jump and oh yeah after all that
just sent me ahead grab
125 shoddy shots 208 you win I do yeah
okay okay I just go this way
maybe I cuz in this game you have to
double back a lot maybe this is one of
those moments because I've definitely
yeah I've definitely already been here
before so I think we had to go through
all that just to turn the fan on
oh right you know what I mean with like
affected something and now we can like
proceeding yeah we can go all the way
back here and something should be
different shooting at you
back to our back to our boy okay it's
good thing anyways all those grenades
I just jumped down instead of having to
like
I mean I think that that did find us
solve the problem
because that would have had a company
here anyway but
significantly
oh love it
and made the jump
here
[Music]
[Laughter]
enjoy a meal
we against somewhere
you have five more minutes David so we
can do take out that monster you got
like it's like five chapters I think
it's good amount of half-life I think I
got a jump we know how this will boy
yeah save two times real casual here
radiation great I blame all of you that
was a pretty fast
I'm shooting the second you missed like
that part right there I was like he's
done do you want to talk about emotion 6
I know I'm trying to survive it's like
if I was playing it wouldn't be an issue
yo this guy is looking for something yes
I just turned it on I think - oh yeah
[Laughter]
sick hiding spot bro don't tell anyone
I'm here shut up I got to eat this I'm
nosy
[Music]
I better get zapped
yeah so much for that hiding spot broski
oh you're gonna fall off but save real
quick oh my god it might be supposed to
go in the thing I don't think so I
wonder if I just leave
these talks here sound effects on a
track show do you David Mann back to
square one bro oh oh look what you done
did that's why we got these these things
which is
you're not gonna make this jump over
that you don't think so I know so David
played this game she's no momentum man
I'm just pushing this way more out there
I just want to say hi to the boss or
before I say goodbye
oh my goodness okay huh
you got got yeah yeah it was like that's
a lot of work just to get across a
puddle wouldn't put it past them all
right where's my friend where's my pal
so I'm making a ruckus so I save every
time yeah it's like it's gonna happen
the momentum of the movement
a wall run
[Music]
nice if you make the sound effect you'd
go further
[Music]
see if this tie was hang at the crotch
around him all couch around like or else
he could hear you uh word we're okay
like the this is the this is a special
part of the stream guys
you've gotta beat this guy and then
never ah bro I don't anything I'm gonna
beat this guy I think we're just gonna
just gonna call it
[Music]
he's here like a it's gotta be an
eventual limit where I don't know if he
takes like a certain amount of bullets
or if he just
like
just waste my entire clip all 99er chat
kit uh oh okay yeah they want me to go
up yeah they do want me to go up boys
why you're the gamer and I'm the guy
getting rekt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow was that thought okay here's another
ladder up there
just be quiet me go
last night damn meanwhile this guy here
this whole time don't make me do this he
almost destroyed you
he why'd you do that don't make me do
this wait what about the other
oh he's so you still got to turn on two
more things we just got the power yeah
word all right in that case well in that
case that is gonna be the end of our
stream today y'all on that that
concludes our time but we hope you
enjoyed a reminiscence you have you
enjoyed that tool with Barney Calhoun
man jeez it was a good time and yeah you
know we just had to have to reminisce a
little bit and in that that is that
everybody was a lot of fun yes
happy Tuesday hope you guys have a great
Thanksgiving if you are celebrating that
where you are located and yeah we will
see you guys tomorrow or maybe not us
specifically community Fridays has been
moved to community Wednesday since we
won't be here on Thursday or Friday and
the guys miss you so tune in for that
tomorrow and until next time we'll see
you guys later
take care guys